salut c'est Hugo cette semaine dans la
grande histoire je voulais vous partager
notre série documentaire consacré à un
mouvement à l'image sulfureuse les
skinad dans ce premier épisode vous
allez voir qu'à l'époque les skinad
c'étaient pas du tout comme aujourd'hui
ils étaient apollytiques ils écoutter du
ska et du réget et tout le monde était
le bienvenu dans leur bande les blancs
les noirs et les maghrébains mais ça
c'était avant pour comprendre comment ce
mouvement a basculé on a fait le choix
d'aller aussi interroger les plus
extrêmes d'entre eux pour montrer qui
ils sont
réellement j'ai commencé à voir tous les
gens que j'avais frappé tout ce mal que
j'avais
fait ça m'a rendu extrêmement
triste été un long cheminement cette ha
qui chercher cette colère ces pulsions
quoi peut-être que j'aurais pas eu toute
cette haine j'aurais pas voulu
rechercher autant
l'amour quand je pense à travers la
violence tout ce que j'ai fait ou à
travers mes idées mais ouais ça a été
des flashes
terribles c'est pas c'est pas facile de
changer tu sais c'est extrêmement
difficile moment où j'ai senti le besoin
de me repentir
c'est quand tout ce film de ma vie s'est
déroulé à l'intérieur de
[Applaudissements]
moi moi j'ai pas démarche ni religieuse
ni sectaire donc je suis pas dans son
truc
mais il se repentit de
quoi vivent dans la haine dans la
violence la bière le racisme et leur
idole c'est Hitler
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vipression pour le M
je
c'est bon peut
[Musique]
commencer à l'époque beaucoup de mes
confrères font le rapprochement entre
skin et extrême droite à tort en
oubliant qu'à l'origine ce mouvement
n'est nullement d'extrême droite et
raciste c'est même totalement le
contraire CIT un mouvement dans les
années 60 en Angleterre qui prenait
l'écoute de la musique jamais et les
relations avec les immigrés jamaïcains à
[Musique]
Londres on peut considérer que le
mouvement skin c'est une histoire
musicale ce sont des jeunes prol anglais
qui vont emprunter au jamaïain leur
musique le style une partie de leur
style vestimentaire et créé un style
original dans la tradition anglaise
c'est black and white en gros les
pauvres noirs et les pauvres blancs qui
fréquentent les mêmes quartiers des
grandes
britannique cette culture skin elle
émerge comme
ça les skin écoutent du des skin
écoutent du réget il faut enlever ce
myth où les mecs ils écoutent que du
pogo c'est les
f les skin sont l'exemple même d'un
mouvement
[Musique]
métissé
les skin vont vraiment incarner d'abord
vestimentairement leur ancrage dans la
classe
ouvrière je viens d'une cité mes parents
ét ouvriers pour êre faut pour moi à la
base fallait être prolétaire au départ
c'était surtout portter des des
boots des grosses chaussures qui étaient
considéré comme des chaussures de
chantier donc il vont outrer ce style
prolétéien avec les chemises le port des
bretelles les cheveux cour était très
porté dans la classe ouvrière en général
pour des raisons de d'hygiène ou de
sécurité pour les gens qui étaient soit
dans l'mtié de la restauration soit
travaillai derrière des machine c'était
pas un élément qui était forcément
choquant à l'époque
ensuite vous avez les années 70 le le
mouvement disparaît plus ou
moins puis réapparaît dans le sillage du
mouvement punk au début des années
il provoque par l'accoutrement et par le
geste ce sont les Pun punk ça veut dire
paumer raté min autrefois c'était une
insu aujourd'hui être punk avoir l'air
taré c'est une
aspiration c'est le punk qui va initier
un revival skinad le mouvement skinad ça
se greffe sur la musique
punk vous pas l'impression d'être un peu
fachaud sur les bords non ouais on est
faud ça fait chier les gens
cette exception de la violence c'est
quelque chose qui va rester quelque part
dans l'ADN du mouvement
skin dans le sillage du punk il va avoir
un souscourant qui va s'appeler
la la va se revendiquer comme étant du
du punk de la rue de la vraie working
class musique et donc à ce titre va
devenir la musique référentielle des
[Musique]
skin
je me suis pris la vague punk en pleine
face ça m'a scch et en fait la musique
skin est encore plus forte que le punk
je suis devenu skin après avoir été punk
tout simplement c'est un peu l'étape
supérieure du Pun une époù le Pun fait
moins
peur skin fait plus
peur
en France les tout premiers skin sont
apparus en
78 à de pas de l'église saintostache il
y a déjà le r le métro et bientôt le
forum commercial les loyers sont pas
chers ici au moment où on évacue les de
Paris pour aller sur
R
et donc il y a une faune une vraie
Faun lieu de prédilection de touses
marginaux deg de de méro jour des
je notre point de ralliment c'était la
fontaine des Innocents qui dans le
passé abrit la cour des
[Musique]
miraclesve ard les fugurs les clochards
aujourd'hui les bandes il y avait un
noyau dur on va dire une quinzaine et
des gens qui passa qui se Greff à nous
des zonards comme on
dit UNE hondelle tatouée je sais ce que
ça veut dire une toile d'araignée là
c'est pareil c'est les skins c'est leur
truc il faut bien comprendre que les
skin il y a pas que des blancs il y a
beaucoup de qu il y a beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de
Maghrébins
beaucoup dans la Vande il y avait un
asiatique un
reevux on était dans un mouvement libre
pas de
chef une vraie
bande
maman est juif polonaise et papa est
kabil moi j'ai une maîtresse d'école qui
a demandé à ma mère de changer mon
prénom au lieu de mettre Homar de
choisir en un weekend
Philippe voilà c'est pour ça que je l'ai
tatoué dans le
cou je me nomme amour et dans les années
80 je faisais partie d'une bande et on
traînit au
Hal skin pour la musique skin pour la
provocation sont des des gens qui aiment
bien [__] la merde provoquer faire
parler d'eux il fallait faire ses
preuves il fallait pouvoir garder ses
doed fallait pouvoir porter Sonon
fallait parce que ça faisait partie ça
se méritait
je m'appelle Fabian j'tais skin à Paris
dans les années
80 au tout début j'étais avec
skin on avait les même goû musicau les
mêm
vestimentaires j'aurais aimé la moto
peuttre que je seru B là j'aimais le
foot la musique F et puis l'alcool je
fallait pas nous chercher enfin pareil
on défendait la fontaine c'était notre
notre château fort à nous quand on y
avait un problème qui venait deextérieur
on était tous tous ensemble on fait
parti voilà c'est la famille c'est on
touch un des nôres et ben on touche à
tout le
[Musique]
monde on était des gamins des sales
gosse voilà en fait au lieu de faire les
bêtises à la maison on les faisait dans
la rue kikiner les
gens si vous vouliez une une paire de
doc il y avait deux solutions vous allé
en Angleterre ou alors vous la
dépouillez c'est le pauvre qui volle le
riche ah tu as des dogs tu fais du
combien bah maintenant tu vas les
enlever Ctait skin ouais à quelle époque
début 80 l'époque des moi j'étais que
oh bonne journée merci à toi aussi
hein peut-être qu'on l'a dépouillé je
sais pas mais tu vois ça se passe non
mais
sérieux c'est pas elle tourne pas la
caméra là si
[Musique]
ah sociologiquement sont des jeunes qui
viennent de de Bonlieu souvent de milieu
défavorisé qui restent assez punk dans
dans leur comportement c'estàd avec les
addictions à l'alcool à la drogue
malheureusement pour pour les h il y a
eu des problèmes de il y en a qui sont
tombés dans la Droid il y en a qui sont
tombés dans il y en a qui en sont morts
et enfin bon
voilà les skin politiques il vont venir
après eux vont vouloir fonder une image
du du skin plus dur plus politisé plus
[Musique]
discipliné le clan évolution m au début
c une bande un peu nationaliste surtout
violent c'est une évolution nationale
socialiste du
[Applaudissements]
mouvement le premier groupe politique
pour eux skin ça va être le nazi skin et
ça va se faire notamment par
l'entreogent de Serge Ayoub qui va
chercher à politiser mouvement skinet
[Musique]
français Serge aou j'ai photographié en
87 il est tout Mince il est déterminé
c'est c'est un Fighter
sergeillou Serge ayoup qui se fait
connaître au début des années 80 est à
l'époque avant tout un militant
politique il n'était pas ce qui nide au
sens musical et culturel du terme je
pense qu'à l'époque avec Serge Ayoub on
est dans un autre monde vous avez tapé
souvent sur la gueule des gens
ouais combien de personnes à peu près
vous avez je sais pas j'ai pas la
mémoire des
chiffres quand on aime on compte pas
c'était quoi son
surnomin pourquoi éta toujours avec une
balle de baseball voilà donc ça lui avu
surnom c'est quelqu'un qui veut pas
perdre si M souvir sont bon c'était
surtout ça quand vous voulez pas perdre
même si vous savez pas vous battre vous
obtenz gain de cause c'est un
principe il a un discours politique qui
qui est très construit
sur le l'immigration et cetera et quel
ce discours bah qu'il faut faire la loi
que je sais pas demandez-lui à lui aussi
vous savez ça c'est des gens il faut pas
me demander à moi ce qui ce qu'ils
pensent et ce qu'ils disent voyez moi
j'ai mes règles je suis encore là je
suis encore en vie ça fait 47 ans que je
fais ça
donc je me Pr Serge je suis un parisien
etsu de la ceinture rouge c'est le Paris
populaire et j'ai adhéré à une mouvance
qui était
skinad j'ai d'abord formé mes mecs sur
Gambetta et après on s'est rapatrié sur
[Musique]
Saint-Michel il y a un gourou il y a un
gourou avec ses codes ses valeurs et
cetera puis autour il y a y a les
membres du groupe quoi qui qui sont là
et qui écoutent religieusement et qui
qui opèent comme on leur demande
d'opérer j'espère que ce premier épisode
vous a intéressé un grand merci à
Aurélie Simon et Nicolas Dumont avec qui
j'ai eu la chance de réaliser cette
série documentaire un grand merci
également à Mathias ilon et
Jean-Christophe Marco et à toutes les
équipes de brut qui ont participé à sa
fabrication n'hésitez pas à poser un
like et à vous abonner à la chaîne pour
ne rien rater de nos prochaines vidéos
et je vous donne rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine pour le deuxème épisode de la
série
skined